wer hat das irgendwann mal so festgelegt
dass man in deutschland so frühstück zum
mittag ist und so abend ist bis zur
frühen neuzeit basierten alle in europa
verbreiteten getränk auf alkohol
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem unscharfen video jetzt ist ne
leute was geht ab ich habe natürlich
euch geht es gut mir auch und zwar
blende ich euch jemals stellen kommentar
ein
den fand ich so genial also ich habe
selten so einen genialen kommentar
gelesen
deswegen fahre ich sage mal richtig wenn
er richtig viele kommentare schreibt mit
richtig vielen ideen für videos die ich
halt machen soll auf jeden fall hatte
jemand geschrieben
alex macht doch mal ein video wo du
einen tag lang sozusagen diese ganzen
mahlzeiten verteilt wie zum beispiel
halt zum frühstück abendessen zu mittag
essen kuchen also das ist ja sonst
nachmittags nein
doch zum abendessen frühstück also
sollte ja eigentlich jeder von euch
verstehen worum es geht und ich habe mir
gedacht das ist wirklich eine richtig
gute idee weil er hat es mal probiert so
niemand dazu muss ich erst mal sagen
jetzt ist hier aber irgendwie ist das ja
noch ganz normal dass man hals zum
frühstück mehr so brötchen ist der saft
trinkt ford flex toastbrot keine ahnung
hat ja jeder so seine gewissen
angewohnheiten zum mittagessen gibt es
dann eine warme mahlzeit abends bei
vielen sicherlich oder da gibt es
meinetwegen abends was waren das mittags
noch brot was weiß ich das ja überall
unterschiedlich trotzdem denke ich mal
dass die meisten so mittags war müssen
und man gewöhnt sich daran und man kann
sich auch nicht vorstellen okay ich bin
jetzt auf gestanden jetzt gibt es
erstmals eine pizza oder so die fälle
gibt sicherlich auch allerdings würde
ich mal sagen dass ich normal und
deswegen finde ich die idee extrem gut
und wie man sehen kann also ist ja ein
ganz klarer beweis dass das video
wirklich will wird draußen ist gerade
dunkel und die lampe ist irgendwie immer
noch kaputt und ja gestalten einfach
mit der 24 stunden challenge also 24
stunden alle mahlzeiten vertauscht und
ich bin wirklich mal gespannt wie es
wird
ob ich dann sage so wenn ich zum
frühstück irgendwie ware mahlzeit esse
aber das ist jetzt aber echt eklig wir
gehen jetzt erst mal einkaufen frühstück
halt also das gibt es hier sicherlich
noch nicht fest von überzeugt ich würde
sagen jetzt gibt noch nach oben wenn ihr
die idee feiert und schreibt weitere
channels in den kommentaren für 24
stunden stellendes let's go so wie kann
man sich so einen orangensaft pressen
das machen wir mal
hier haben wir schon brötchen und
croissants
die könnte ich auch noch mitnehmen ich
würde sagen die hier nehmen wir mal
mitgenommen früh oder doch lieber das
passt schon eher zu richten aber noch
irgendeine joghurt so als nachtisch
mäßig so leute jetzt ist mir auch noch
mal eine tüte gerissen ist gleich und
auf jeden fall so weit fertig ich bin
jetzt wieder zurück und ich zeige mich
mal kurz was ich alles geholt haben hier
immer das frühstücksbrötchen wir haben
himbeeren frisch gepressten saft den
hole ich mir sonst auch wirklich sehr
oft schmeckt gut und ist auch ganz
gesund hier die marmelade habe ich auch
noch geholt dazu mache ich mir jetzt so
ein auf brötchen da habe ich nämlich
gelernt dass sie wirklich sehr lecker
schmecken im letzten video oder
irgendwann vor zwei wochen habe ich mal
so eine tiefe challenge gemacht viele
haben sich auch darüber aufgeregt dass
ich so gesagt habe jetzt alles verloren
gesund ihr habt mich überzeugt sagen das
war so als ich mache mir jetzt eben ein
frühstück zum abendessen und dann sehen
wir uns nicht wieder
bis gleich ach leute was natürlich auch
nicht fehlen darf ist mir aufgefallen
ist der kaffee das hier ist nämlich
meine eigene kaffeemaschine war und ich
bin ja so stolz drauf
ich hab das schon auf instagram it zeigt
wenn ihr mir da noch nicht folgt macht
das sehr gerne da heiße ich einfach alex
wie vor allem weil es den krassen
projekt gibt das seht ihr nur dort in
der industrie deswegen folgte fenster
dann würde ich mich sehr darüber freuen
auf jeden fall kurz die kaffee ecke hier
haben wir ein paar tassen
dann könne das ist dann hier der
vollautomat von philips und hier habe
ich noch diesen kühlschrank mit milch
drin egal wir machen uns stellen kaffee
und dann bin ich auch schon fertig mit
dem frühstück schmeckt wirklich sehr gut
ich muss sagen ich bin wirklich müde so
also der tag mit war echt anstrengend
aber das wird sich ja gleich ändern
also ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern
dass ich jeden fall schon mal abends in
meinem leben einen kaffee getrunken habe
so der erste teller
ich trinke tee saft einfach heraus kein
bock ex fernglas gefällt leute also dass
früchte jetzt fertig und ich muss noch
ganz kurz schön hinstellen
ja sagt tag sieht auf jeden fall ganz
cool aus ich würde sagen 30
irgendwie sieht das auf dieser käme
jetzt nicht besonders schön aus ihrem
hier die himbeeren hier haben wir auch
brötchen mit brandschützer brötchen
croissants marmelade obst obst zu saft
und der kaffee dann würde ich einfach
mal sagen guten appetit
[Musik]
so leute ich hab aufgefrischt abendessen
also die mischung aus frühstück und
abendessen wir haben jetzt halb neun und
an sich also ich fand es eigentlich
überhaupt nicht schlimm war ganz lecker
so ich denke nämlich mal eher umgekehrt
ist es viel schwieriger
anstatt so abends was süßes zuerst oder
marmelade wein wegen kaffee orangensaft
wenn ich dann morgen früher aber diese
spaghetti mache um 8 9 uhr morgens bin
ich mal gespannt wie das wird habe ich
auch vorher noch nie gemacht um diese
uhrzeit und ja ich würde sagen hier
später schlafen so im 11.12.10 sehen wir
uns morgen früh
das war es von dem ersten tag also gut
weist auch nicht lange alle leute bis
morgen früh dann morgen als das wetter
ist auf jeden fall leute was geht ab und
damit einen guten morgen ich habe gerade
geduscht und bau hat das wetter ist
richtig gut was schon lange nicht mehr
hier
na gut ich war noch länger nicht hier
auf jeden fall haben wir jetzt kurz nach
jetzt bin ich wirklich mal gespannt
beziehen ist ja natürlich durch und ich
würde sagen wir machen uns erst mal
frühstück erst mal muss ich auch kurz
mein bett machen leute hier nochmals
ferner weiß 95 16 könnte mir auch mal
schnell die haare machen
ich weiß natürlich könnte die urteile
auf eine probe stellen also es ist jetzt
wirklich morgens ich finde das kann man
auch so an der sonne sehen egal also wir
machen ja still die nudeln ich bin mal
gespannt jetzt würde ich ja zu sagen so
ich habe da überhaupt keinen bock drauf
sondern mehr so auf und brötchen und
kaffee und saft ist ja auch klar aber
das geht halt nicht so die nudeln sind
im topf und das riecht wirklich verdammt
ich könnte etwas besseres vorstellen
okay leute also hier haben wir die
nudeln sieht jetzt nicht besonders
lecker aus aber da habe ich auch schnell
gemacht ich muss sagen also das hat
jetzt ungefähr
20 minuten gedauert und man kocht die
dann so und riecht das halt die ganze
zeit und am anfang denkt man sich so ok
eigentlich habe ich da jetzt gar keinen
bock drauf aber ich glaube es ist jetzt
ganz so schlimm dass jetzt zu essen also
ich würde einfach mal sagen guten
appetit halb 10 pa nudel geht glasgow
dann stand es drauf für drei portionen
ich weiß jetzt zwar nicht für wen das
bestimmt ist aber erwachsene portionen
sind das hier habe ich dann nicht ich
komme mir irgendwie ein bisschen
außergewöhnlich das wort ich komme mir
bisschen außergewöhnlich vor
ich habe jetzt nicht mal die hälfte
geschafft und irgendwie habe ich schon
also ich habe überhaupt keinen bock mir
das jetzt durch gegen die wenn ich
komischerweise auch schon sagt also
normalerweise erst zum frühstück gab es
gerne um mehr als das so also ich hätte
nicht gedacht aber es ist schon härter
als man sich das vorstellt ich bin
irgendwie einfach schön und ich habe
absolut kein bock merken jetzt mir noch
so ein paar nudeln hier sein kann ich
nicht mithalten so leute das was mit dem
frühstück ich habe nicht ganz aufgegeben
muss ich ehrlich sagen ich bin jetzt
auch wirklich einfach sagt was auch noch
hinzu kommt die soße war so ein bisschen
scharf und irgendwie ich weiß ich das
vertrage ich auch nicht sehr gut morgen
zumindest ist der körper halt ich glaube
einfach nicht darauf eingestellt es ist
einfach so und das ist es dann so eine
sache da frage ich mich wer hat das
irgendwann mal so festgelegt dass man in
deutschland so frühstück so mittag ist
und so abend ist das ist wahrscheinlich
so eine entwicklung über extrem viele
jahre
vielleicht haben die menschen ja vor
2000 jahren zum frühstück warmes essen
gegessen also hauptsächlich es kultur
der frühen 19
die küche des frühzeitlichen europa ist
eine mischung der mittelalterlichen
küche mit bis in die neuzeit reichende
neuerungen bis zur frühen neuzeit
basierten alle in europa verbreiteten
getränke auf alkohol ganz so kleinen
kindern wir geben jedermann auch der
ärmste trank täglich und zu jeder
mahlzeit milde alkoholische getränke
kamen die menschen dann durchgehend
besoffen oder es in den meisten
europäischen region waren jetzt zwei
mahlzeiten an der tagesordnung einer
morgen ein am späten abend leute wenn
ihr euch damit auskennt schreibt mir das
sehr gerne mal in die kommentare ich
möchte generell aus dem text nicht so
schlau wir gehen jetzt gleich erstmal
mittagessen im café
sollte ich würde sagen wir gehen jetzt
schnell mittagessen als ich gehe hier
einfach um die ecke zum bäcker weil die
haben das natürlich auch schon ab
morgens dann so kuchen und so und nicht
erst das dann einfach mal jetzt um diese
uhrzeit in der bäckerei so machte ich
erklären so teenies und dazu noch so ein
wetter teigwaren und kompetenzen
nein ich bin leider schon wieder zurück
das ding ist in diesem café also da
gibts nur fünf plätze oder so und der
war da war jeder platz besetzt wird
irgendeiner oma oder einen opa die sich
da irgendwie zum mittags kaffee oder
sogar dass wir jetzt 13 19
heute ist hier so ein roboter angekommen
dazu gibt es doch mehr an weiteren
videos auf jeden fall habe ich mir
folgende sachen geholt wenn ihr
aufnehmen das video abschneiden
das hier sind zwar teenies was ich aber
noch sagen wollte ich habe nicht mal
wirklich hunger irgendwie nach dem
nudelholz morgen dann habe ich mir noch
diese stehen hier geholt wurde habe ich
früher so gerne gegessen heißt nicht
schweinchen jetzt habe ich noch mit
meinem café geklettert was ich noch
sagen wollte so einen kaffee habe ich
mir schon öfters eingezogen oder
schmeckt aber nicht so gut
[Musik]
das ist echt hart
wer wird irgendwie schlecht davon das
ist jetzt ich würde mir anstellen aber
können dass ich muss wirklich leider
sagen mein fazit wäre jetzt abends was
süßes essen ist überhaupt kein problem
aber morgens was warmes oder was
deftiges und mittags dann wieder was
süßes essen da bin ich raus also dass
hier können sie gern mal selber
ausprobieren aber mir geht's damit
überhaupt nicht gut merkt man ja
vielleicht auch gerade also das ist das
fazit von diesem video ich will mich da
ist auch gar nicht weiter mit quellen
ich würde einfach sagen das war's ja
einiges zu vergessen gibt mir sehr gerne
daumen nach oben für weitere experimente
einfach in den kommentaren schreiben was
für ein kommentar ihr euch und
kommentiert wollten auf jeden fall auf
instagram da ist alex ii und wir sehen
uns morgen wieder da gibt es neues
cooles video haut rein